For this problem, we're about the claim the spaceships.
Actually, we're dealing with the Apollo 13 mission. We should go from 1970.
They were supposed to take astronauts from the earth and land them on the moon.
However, at some point during the trip, they encountered a problem
with one of their oxygen tanks and they had to abort their mission of landing on the moon
and instead figure out how to get the crew back to the earth safely.
Well in this problem, we're going to show how changing the velocity of the ship
using boost rockets can change the trajectory of the ship to make it loop around the earth
instead of landing on the moon and bring it back to where it started on the earth.
This is definitely the most complex part that we've given you so far.
So don't worry if it seems a little bit complicated at first.
I'm going to help you out by continuing to chunk and giving you some hints.
As always, we told you some important information to start up with.
We have some information about the earth and gravity,
and also significant information about the moon including the period of the moon
or the time that it takes the moon to orbit around the earth.
Well, once you have unique value that you see here is no initial angle
and this is just the angle at which the moon is initially placed from the earth.
This is a zero degree or 0 radian line and the angle between this line
and the position vector of the moon is equal to moon initial angle.
Let's have the total duration of the flight that we're considering in the times measured in meters
which has resulted to local truncation air that we're going to allow the flight path to have.
Well, Jorn mentioned this brief in the unit,
and I'll give you little bit more explanation about it in a minute.
We've laid out five tasks for you to complete to make it fundamental as a cohesive halt.
The first one, which you can see right here, is to find
the moon's position vector as a function of time.
And here we're going to consider the earth is the origin here,
as the position vector of the moon is just the vector from the earth to the moon.
Now remember this is dependent on time.
You can also say that the moon is going to move in counter clockwise around the earth
or at least that's how it looks in this picture.
Then the next thing that you need to figure out
is how to calculate this spaceship's acceleration to the gravity.
Well the input here is time and position.
The position right here is not the same as position that you just computed in the task above.
Instead, this position is a position of the spacecraft and not of the moon.
So the second task is going to define the position of the spaceship depending on time
and then you need to figure out how the gravitational attraction
to the earth and to the moon affected deceleration.
You think about how you can use vectors to do this and also as I said earlier,
pretend that the earth is not the origin.
Well, each of the first two tasks notice what your return values are
and make sure that you define variables with the event in their proper places and it's function.
So now you come to the slightly trickier part.
In order to adjust the spaceship's trajectory to make it go around the moon,
and then back in the right spot on the earth.
It would be helpful if the crew had some control over it's velocity during the flight,
lucky for them and lucky for us too.
Those spaceship has rocket mechanisms that will allow to reduce it's speed on the way to the moon
and increase it's speed on the way back to the earth.
And we applied boost function right here. We've created two variant variables for you.
And now I'm going to help you program some of these changes in velocity.
This first one first two mid course correction or MCC
and this task is whether or not the initial deceleration has occurred.
Right now, it's set to false since at the beginning of the flight, this hasn't happened yet.
Similarly, we have a second variable which at first does descent propulsion system or TPS.
And this represents a second change in velocity.
And the amount of which we're going to change the velocity at this point
is what we're going to call the variable boost.
Now, at these two moments, remember that we want to change just the management of the velocity.
We don't want to mess with the direction at all. That would deal with itself.
So, if your task is going to be to include these two velocities shifts
and of course include them at the right times which I listed in the code.
You can notice in the setup position of velocity vectors for you right here
and plugged the initial values as well; however, it's up to you to figure out
how to adjust their values with each step using Jorn's method and adapt a step size.
You're going to that down here in this while loop.
Here's Jorn's for you just to help you out a little bit.
Once you calculated position and velocity using Heun's method.
We also need to adjust the step size of the end of the while loop
to reset it was a new value for the next time that we go to the loop.
Now, just as we did in section 12 of the unit, we're going to store whatever the present step size is as h.
And whatever the step size that would be in the next step of h new.
To figure out the relationship between h and h new,
you need to calculate the local truncation error or LTE.
We also use basically the error that is made in a single time step.
The difference after each time step between exact quantity
and the quantity estimated by the approximation method that we're using.
So new step size, h new is going to depend on the current step size,
the tolerance, which we gave you earlier and the LTE.
So consider calculating a local truncation error takes into account
the difference between the values of position calculated by Euler and by Heun
and the difference in values of velocity.
T right here is the total duration of the flight so far.
This needs to be here to let all of the units line up and LTE to be measured in length.
Once you filled everything in, we're going back to the top of the applied boost function
and figure out what the proper value of the constant boost is.
Remember that our goal is to get the spaceship all the way around the moon
and then have it just as it touches the earth when it comes back.
Once you filled in everything down here, go back to the top of the applied boost function
and figure out what the proper value for the constant boost is.
We've given you just an initial value of zero, but we've also given you some other values to try out.
So try plugging each these in and see what happens.
Remember that our goal is put the spaceship all the way around the moon
and then come back the earth and just touch the place where it initially took off.
And because of the total time that we set at the top of our code,
the shoot trajectory is not actually going to stop in the plot right initially when the ship gets to the earth.
Instead, it's going to continue out in the earth as the spaceship
is going to go back to the moon the second time.
And the reason we did this was to try to make it a little bit easier for you
to tell which value of the boost you should use.
The correct value of boost will have the tail of it's trajectory
reaching just back to the radius of the moon's orbit.
Incorrect values of these could make the trajectory end short, go off in the wrong direction,
but even if the spaceship crash into the earth which we definitely don't want to happen.
And I'm sure the crew doesn't either.
Well, now that this is a complex problem, but I'm sure you'll be able to return the crew safely home.
If you need any help, just come to the front